the jury has rendered its verdict on joe
burrow after only two games you alluded
to this earlier
he's got it he's he's got it and and i
look and and he showed to me growth from
sunday to thursday he ironed out some
goofy mistakes that he made against the
chargers
he was focused last night he was
spraying the ball all over the place
completed passes to eight different
receivers 61 throws second most all-time
single game for the bengals most
ever in an on overtime game for the
bengals 37 completions
tied for second most in a single bengals
game and the most
ever for a rookie beating carson wentz
and chris winky who had been tied with
36 so
burro has got it and here's the other
reason why he's got it from 15-0 last
year to owen two this year he's pissed
off about losing and he's not going to
take it anymore here he is from after
the game
losing isn't very fun um
you know this might be the only time in
my sporting career that i've lost two
games in a row
doesn't feel very good
you know peter you made the point last
year about kyla murray
as he was heading into the nfl how is he
going to deal with losing because he
never has
he never has and you're going to the
worst team in the nfl
you're going to lose and we saw kyler
murray process it deal with it and fight
through it and he's ready to explode
this
year joe burrows going to have to deal
with it and process it and
look the thing is every game they're
going to be kicking and screaming
even if they lose all 16 burrow is going
to
insist that they go into every game with
the mentality that they will win
and that they never give up until the
very end and we saw that start to finish
against the charters and we saw it start
to finish against the browns
in 1998 sports illustrated sent me
to a game at the end of peyton manning's
rookie year
uh the colts at baltimore and
uh the colts got creamed and they were i
don't know what their record was
three and 11 maybe they were awful
and but every snap of that game
peyton manning battled like it was the
last play of his life
and afterwards i spent a little bit of
time with him but i will
and not you know he said hey you know
whatever i
i don't i don't even remember what he
said but i'll never forget when i talked
to jim mora
and remember jim moore is a fiery dude
and
it doesn't matter that i because i said
to him
jim i know it doesn't seem like it now
but i'll tell you what
that quarterback is going to be good you
guys are making progress
this is a pill you have to swallow blah
blah blah and he goes
the hell with that he said i hate losing
and
and he went he he just went off about it
and i understood it
but there comes a time
that you look at a quarterback and you
look at a team and i'm not saying he's
going to be peyton manning
all i'm saying is that you see
a player in the first two games of the
year
last night on the road first road game
in the nfl
very shaky protection very shaky
he leads six scoring drives you know and
again he can't play defense
he doesn't have a bunch of grant dell
pits you know on
on his defense necessarily and and and
you know at lsu you
you're gonna have the best players but
but my only point is
if you live in cincinnati or you love
the bengals and you have been
waiting for years for
a sign that okay we're gonna get out of
the wilderness now
okay this to me and again with all due
respect to andy dalton
who led them to respectability he really
did you can't criticize that
but to me this is like what it was like
in the mid 80s
in cincinnati when they drafted boomer
osiasin
and they had that wacky offense with sam
wyche
and every game was an event
and everybody mike is going to be
watching the bengals
this year because it's just like what
lebron james said last night
this kid has it and again
it's only two games you never know and i
don't mean to say
he's peyton manning i don't all i am
saying
is that there's something here that is
going to lift the bengals
and you shouldn't be that concerned
about wins and losses right now
don't care about the record you know
care about the development of this
quarterback
and rarely does such a bad team shed the
sh
from the it so quickly can i say that oh
well i already did
i think i can separate the two right
well we'll find out we'll find out we're
about to go to break maybe we'll be back
maybe we won't but
but to have that that boomerang that
reversal
from being so bad to now you've got hope
and
peter here's the concern though and this
is the thing that's going to keep people
on the edge of their seats
joe burrow took a lot of hits last night
he took a lot of hits against the
chargers he runs with reckless abandon
he has no concern for his body let's
hear a little bit about what happened to
him last night
seven quarterback hits three sacks
including
a a critical strip sack fumble when he
got
hit by miles garrett then blown up by
another bronze player here's some sound
from last night
on burrow taking a pounding the guy's
tough
he took a lot of shots and he bounced
right back up
you know he was he was still putting
putting deep ones on the money and he
was you know always kept his eyes
downfield and he was never really
worried about the rush unless he was it
was really on him
makes me feel like a football player i
kind of like getting hit sometimes
so it's not it doesn't disrupt me
yeah i mean it makes you feel like a
football player until you can't get up
and walk i mean that's the problem
it's football it's physical that's fine
but you're at a level now
where you get hit enough by those guys
something is going to break
or sprain tear whatever
and you're not going to be able to have
a long healthy career there's a reason
why we've been praising kyler murray all
week for his ability
to slide wherever he is for his
awareness when it comes to avoiding
contact we
want quarterbacks to do that and hey
great through two games joe borrows
taking it
he's not going to take it through 16. at
some point he's going to have a hard
time getting up at some point
he's going to be on the injury report
unless he's gumby or something which i
guess is possible but that's the one big
concern i still have with joe burrow
peter
he's yet to realize number one it hurts
and number two it's going to lead to
injury
he's kind of got you know an eli body
doesn't he he he looks like he looks
like he could be a
a stock broker or something you know
he's not
one of these he's not one of these you
know
big hefty guys you know he's a he's a
slight
guy and so i understand what you're
saying mike but again
you know kyler murray's a slight guy too
and you saw
the other day when he ran for that
touchdown at san francisco
how incredible a weapon he is in the
open field
and i don't think you want to take that
away from him i agree with you
you do not want a quarterback like joe
burrow getting hit as much
you don't want lamar jackson getting hit
as much
and so but but i do think
that they've got to find their way
offensively
and they have to see what works for him
uh but i totally agree with you
he's got to keep himself out of harm's
way yeah
and uh right now he's embracing it and
he will embrace it until the moment that
he no longer does and realizes if it's
going to keep you off the field you you
want to find a way to keep yourself
protected aj green's been on the field
for the first two games of the year last
night how about this peter 13 targets
and only three catches and i saw a
couple that i thought man aj green
catches that ball i don't know what's
going on with aj green
but uh that that franchise tag money
they've invested in him this year
when you consider the other weapons they
have and i i was impressed with t
higgins uh they've got tyler boyd who
had a couple of big catches
um i just i just wonder if aj green
uh really fits the long-term vision
there or if this is just going to be it
for him in cincinnati
my guess is that this is it you know the
bengals might be the only
organization in football that that might
want to keep
shelling out the big money for him
because
that's what they do um but i agree
i agree with you mike especially after
taking t
higgins you know as high as they took
him in this draft
i i i would be surprised uh
you know if they hung on to to aj green
after this year now again
aj green might have an absolutely
explosive year
and prove us wrong but in my opinion i'd
be spending the money
uh on the offensive line uh and i'd be
spending the money on a corner
if i were the bengals those are the
places where
uh they are really lacking right now
yeah i mean john ross
not the answer tyler boyd led the way
seven catches with 72 yards
and it's weird to see someone wearing 85
who isn't
chad johnson ocho cinco and that was t
higgins and he flashed at times
last night so they've got a bright
future and
you need guys who are going to catch the
football if your quarterback's going to
throw it 61 times and they're working in
that direction but you're right they
need the offensive line
the running game wasn't there last night
the defense needs to improve other than
that they're on the right track and
that's the thing
joe it's going to take a while the
attitude is great
i just hope they can find a way to win
some games before he
he becomes defeated but i don't think he
will
i think he's always going to have this
attitude get through this
year and then next year maybe the
bengals and think about this peter
the bengals with joe burrow the ravens
with lamar jackson in the same division
i don't know what's going to happen with
baker mayfield i don't know what the
steelers are going to have after ben
rothersburg i mean the one big warning
if you're the steelers you better have a
plan post roethlisberger or you're going
to get potentially left in the dust by
the bengals and the ravens
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports